hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to darkwood all right
let's
not waste time actually time is not
wasting at all
time doesn't seem to be moving okay
interesting
so i'm not gonna give away too much
stuff just because i wanna make sure
that i have what i need
but it seems like maybe time won't pass
until i start
leaving that'd be pretty cool okay so i
got lockpick
oh i can keep stuff in my workbench
oh that's an incredibly better place
than stuffing it into the wardrobe oh
that's infinitely better there's so much
space
there's so much oh
okay fantastic all right you know it's
fine
because this is a learning experience
all of this is a learning experience
the workbench has tons of space great
stuff
that's a it's a net positive
what hi who are you and why did you just
invite yourself into my home
what what okay cool
you know what fine whatever man that's
fine that's totally fine
okay there's that this than that i don't
know oh maybe the meat could be
i could bait a trap with the meat i
could probably do that
i can only assume that as soon as i
leave time's gonna start
so i think i've got everything that i
need i've got that situated i'm just
gonna open up that
and then be on my way why does
everything look all
viney when i'm not looking at it inside
my house but not outside my house
yeah whatever it doesn't matter it's
mosey on out of here also i hope my
generator wasn't running that whole time
or i hope that because time stopped the
generator decides to not
also not stop okay we're out of here
baby we're gonna go south we're gonna
figure out what's going on with this
gas so that we can get out of here i
didn't drink water
ah see time started okay so i'm gonna go
down to this place
and i'm gonna see if there's something
to learn about
why there's a gas and how to counteract
the gas
there might be like a gas mask that i
could kind of
go for down here yeah down here
i mean honestly this wouldn't be too bad
a house to try to defend
i guess oh [ __ ]
i don't know the co where am i where do
they expect me to get these codes from
i can only find so much crap there's gas
in this molotov which is
good let me turn on the generator just
to see if it ah
oh my oh me oh my
hello hello
all right i don't know this poison here
but maybe i can make my way through it
it looks pretty bad and this would
probably kill me but
oh yeah that's no good oh yeah that
that's very bad
okay so that's not happening unless that
is what i'm supposed to do
let me try bashing this
no way okay oh what the hell
oh a shell
great fantastic okay so
either i need healing items to get
through there or i need some kind of a
gas mask
or maybe i could fashion a rag to be
something i don't know
maybe i could burn it that might be a
good idea actually
is it flammable
oh hey i'm smart
oh my god i'm smart guys
it's still burning guys i'm smart guys
i'm smart
and i have oh i don't have gas i don't
have matches anymore damn it
maybe i could wave my torch at it
oh
oh progress oh something's floating
inside the skin looks quite
thin maybe i could puncture or pierce it
with something why would i want to do
that
i'll try it but i don't want to
embryo embryo why am i carrying oh
there's a face on it
look seeing it kind of looks like your
face
no not at all your face isn't drippy and
weird oh
okay
okay all right well i got an embryo
great
really good stuff well
oh god there's a code to get out i
thought that i would oh
man well i got the embryo i'm not sure
why
oh wait there's a back door in wait i
see i see i see i see
i see i almost missed that there's a
back door in here yeah
oh oh yeah
oh hey oh my god oh my god oh my god oh
my god oh my god oh my god
oh my god i will kill you i will kill
you i will kill
you i will kill you come on
oh my god never mind you'll kill me
you'll kill me oh
no oh no
oh no oh no okay
no no no
no you know what no i need to use a
bandage
[Music]
okay oh god here he comes
no no no no okay here we go yep
dodge and then okay he doesn't have that
much health
okay
oh he's almost dead return swing
ah gotcha holy crap
holy crap use your staff
oh man i got him i got him
okay so i'm gonna find out what was in
that room there had to be in some
goodies maybe a code maybe
something something good oh it's locked
from the inside too that doesn't make
much sense
there's a wardrobe here yes bread
delicious bread yes
bread more bread pills
a note okay the door code ah 3333
i can't get any easier remember it i'm
not opening that door after dark anymore
i want to get some gasoline from the pig
shed
i'll be back after dark that's how you
die
that's if i i could have told you that
was how you did the die
thing that's closed so basically
the codes 3333 on both of these doors
got it all right wow but i can lock it
so this actually might be a pretty good
defensible location
it's got light and power doesn't have a
workbench but
hey that's all oh hi hell hello
hi uh
[Music]
map of the forest okay you know what
i probably shouldn't mess with you
silent forest
hideout keotrex house hey there friend
hey hi i searched in the last hideout
look for an exit beneath the floor
all right okay man look uh i can't go
forward cause i'm actually
out of inventory space and i've got a
weird embryo that i'm gonna
not want on me but uh hey progress okay
progress good progress
[Music]
what is this i don't know what that was
just could pretend like it didn't happen
i don't remember moving it that far out
okay whatever it's
it's probably fine alcohol i do need
another torch
uh i have gasoline to make the torch i
think that's
my freaking god stop that
i need to repair my board
that's good make a new torch and then
another bandage the embryo i do not know
what that is about
okay good enough i don't know if
anyone's actually in here and that's
stomping meant
anything but good enough oh god
i could get more i'll get them later if
i need shells which i don't know i need
i'll get them later hey dude how you
doing mind if i take these good thank
you all right bye
ho ho what
what that's a wolf oh my god oh my god
oh my god oh my god
ow oh please don't not no oh my god
oh my god come on yeah
womp oh my god dead huge dog
odd meat weird meat i got weird meat the
big dog
big dog okay well
i did that so that was good
okay more more logs here
is this actually gonna be a hideout of
oh no
no no no no no you didn't see anything
it was weird how there was a lot of
nothing
i'm not going to pick up the logs yet
until i know that there's a reason to
because they take up so much space okay
oh my god oh no no
this place would make a good oh
oh a fan belt oh it would make a good
hideout
oh oh
oh i don't like that i need a key ah not
even a lock pick
okay bread and potato i can't pick it up
i don't know when actual sundown is so i
don't know when to actually
uh make the call of heading back or not
oh there is gas here
what oh my god like the oven
the oven is lit again oh
okay then there's a workbench and
a bike bell well this is a thing
it's definitely a thing okay do i am i
committing to this am i
my am i doing the am i committing
i might be committing i might be
committing but all my [ __ ] is up in the
other place
barricaded window barricaded window okay
where's the defensible
spot here there really isn't one
unfortunately
how much [ __ ] uh so i'm not gonna do it
i'm not gonna do it i'm going back
this is a terrible idea i'm not gonna
make it back oh my god what am i doing
i'm insane
yeah the reason i'm going is because i
don't think that i could have barricaded
the other place
in time how would i have been able to
barricade it i didn't even know if i had
boards or nails i would have gone to get
the logs i would have chopped the logs
up
oh my god night's gonna be at 19 i bet
i'm willing to bet
19 is when it's going to be i must yeah
i i know
i'm aware of these things i'm aware of
them
oh my god oh my god oh my god oh my god
oh my god
oh my god uh gas
uh alcohol this this this this this this
board nail okay and then i'm gonna
barricade this and i'm locked in
it must be it at 20 which would be 8
o'clock
that would make sense the sun is still
going down okay so i had another
hour i didn't know if i had another hour
so i was being a little cautious but
that's okay
caution is good and i've got a lot of
weird [ __ ]
that i could sell to the trader when he
comes if he does come in the morning i
don't know if he will but i've got a lot
of [ __ ]
so that's good i must like the what do
you mean the li
what do you mean what do you mean the
oven's not lit
no no no don't do this to me do not
oh my god light the oven oh my god light
the freaking oven light the freaking
oven
i didn't know that if i did lit another
oven that
it would unlight this one i wasn't aware
of that idea
oh my god please tell me i have enough
to barricade yes hey
what a waste what a waste of materials
what a waste but it's fine
what a waste but it's fine what a waste
but again it is
fine it's a little stressful i'm just
gonna load up my inventory for the
things that i know i'm gonna need
on the journey back and i'm gonna sell
some stuff
oh that's a lot of stomping
[Music]
what what what is that what is it
what is it what is that what is that
about
what is that about what is that about
what is that
no oh no
no no no no no no
what is that about is that a flare did
someone light a flare
why would someone have light a flare
maybe i could make some bear traps
i think technically making a bear trap
gives more value
i don't know what a chain trap is chain
traps even better value
because you can sell them after you make
them
which is cool
no no no no
doing that and why what are you hitting
are you trying to you can't it's too
strong
get away from my window nothing to worry
about
and he's gone perfect
oh here come the whispers
when i oh no not again
no no no no no no no no no no no
no no wow i got my torch
why is my torch not working my torch is
wow hey what the hell
what the hell i'm trying how do i i
don't know
what do i do what do i do
oh my god do not kill me don't kill me
you can't kill me like this that would
be unfair totally unfair
completely unfair completely unfair
[Music]
all right i'm awake and day five
great good stuff all right so what i'm
gonna do
is i'm going to trade everything i can
with the dude i'm gonna i i've got one
full can of gas i'm gonna put away the
stuff that i'm definitely gonna take
with me
i'm gonna trade this the shotgun shells
this weird
embryo the shell dismantle that
i have to oh you do get some back
oh you do not everything of course but
some
hey dude hey hey my friend
my friend you want a weird embryo good
take it
i don't want it there's probably a
reason to keep this
should i sell it i'm gonna keep it but
it's so cursed
all right i'm gonna take that i'm gonna
sell you the chain traps and then
we're gonna accept that you're gonna
take this except that
no room in container he doesn't have
room in his inventory oh
god he has to worry about inventory too
really
we'll cons no consolidate consolidate
your gas cans well you suck
um i'll take your wire then all right
i'm taking that
i guess i keep the embryo then all right
i've got 349 reputation i've traded
around some stuff
i think that it's doing oh i can cook
the embryo
that's why i wouldn't have sold it ah
you know i'll do that
i'll do that and i will dose myself up
all right
good i don't know if i want to eat the
mushrooms i don't think that's a good
idea
heal myself by standing next to an
electric light source once a day i'll be
able to learn my current location on the
map
what do you mean once a day once a day
once i'll pull up the map and be like oh
there i
am is that really going to be useful
sure yeah let's
let's just go with moth because who
knows maybe that'll be good
oh god i've really done it now
[Music]
oh no what did i do what fever dream did
i just
start oh no oh no oh
no oh no what is this nonsense
oh no come
i'm not a dog
you can't treat me that way
shiny stone okay
press your ear against the keyhole i can
hear a faint voice through the howling
wind it sounds familiar it seems to be
coming through the keyhole someone's
calling me
look through the keyhole pick up
oh what am i seeing
what am i saying oh is that what is what
is that
oh please don't be a taint oh is it an
ear i hope it's an
it's at worst it's in here come
come to me you know
oh wha
[Music]
oh shiny stone
shiny stone i got shiny stone
oh oh well dash
that's the worst thing ever that's the
worst thing you could ever put in front
of me
dilapidated children's playground toys
is
is the worst thing
why the screaming there's really a need
to be hush hush about
this area you no need to scream don't
yell
on me all right i'm in the muck
great is that a shiny stone
got you oh good
nice carpet great
oh no
all right yep
uh-huh nightmare no nightmare
nightmare not a nightmare horrifying and
not horrifying
that's bad that's good okay i'm out of
here i thought the dilapidated
children's playground toy would have
been the worst thing
turns out the lamp that sends you into
the hell dimension
turns out that was worse do i have a map
here i can't do that now
no no no no
no no no
i don't want it oh god [ __ ]
i can't survive where do i go
i am oh
i'm alive hey did you see that man i had
a trip my dude
dude dude man i had i went
places anyway
how are you okay let me just quickly
check
my work bench to see what i got i've got
um bread and battery i don't know what
the battery's
for but i have a feeling it's important
it has zero value
which probably means it can't be sold so
it's gotta have something of
importance i just don't know what it is
um i'm gonna grab
something from him and then i'm gonna
mosey him we're gonna we're gonna
book it down to the new area and that
will be our base of operations from now
on
i sold my flares i kind of regret doing
that no let's just do more wood because
i'm gonna need to board up a lot of
windows
oh maybe instead i should do a gas can
there's logs there i can cut my own wood
yeah let's do that instead two gas cans
should be
more than enough okay we're just gonna
haul ass to the new area
dump off all the stuff start barricading
and then get gone
new beginnings new beginnings we're all
about this i probably should have saved
up my run so that as soon as the clock
started i would be able to
actually go but i didn't because i'm
dumb all right
let's get to work we got to fill up this
thing
it's got it's got gas in it which is
good so at least i'll be good for the
first night definitely
and actually i'm wondering did i search
this tractor
fan belt okay that's not good
okay there's a well there i don't know
if this is worth it right uh it's only
four only four i might as well do it
okay
got that oh lots oh lots of good stuff
lots of good stuff
okay lots of good stuff oh wow that that
dog is very dead
why is there a battery in the doghouse
okay
so the place that i can protect
yeah this workbench area this if i can
repair these
which i can apparently then that's all
the better okay oven is lit here
good i don't need to do anything yet the
workbench is right here
by the oven this is excellent this is
most excellent i hate whatever
is happening over there okay but let's
repair this doorway
and i'm gonna drag a light into here
see we're gonna drag this into here
i am so unbelievably slow
and spla-da
good this is definitely gonna get
barricaded
a lot of careful planning going into
this one if that opened the other way
i could actually barricade that doorway
which way does this open
interesting this might not work at all
but it's an option because how would
they
open it up you know what i mean i guess
if they really tried
it might happen but hey it's something
okay it's something
should i build the doorway again uh yeah
is there a way to like lock it no
whatever whatever whatever
whatever whatever drink slurp
okay so battery
ration stamps okay cool
uh great apparently there was a
rationing going on understandable
oh i gotta hurry i am way too slow right
now
i am unbelievably slow right now oh i
need to clear my inventory i'm
just being absolutely inefficient about
this
bandage is all put there gasoline put
there okay god
i'm murdering time okay log
log oh god i'm not moving fast enough oh
god
i'm moving so slow log
log got a lot log got a lot of log
okay i'm just gonna store the logs in
there because i don't know why i didn't
do that before that seems like an
obvious thing to do now yeah okay birds
shut up all right i have just enough
time to do some
minor locale exploration i'm gonna drop
this wood in the workbench and then
i'll be back here by 19 to button up
everything and make sure it's all
hunky-dory
put these away put this away and off we
go
we're going for a real sploor real quick
explore what's in the area
who knows i don't know oh god it's
another dog
hey you wanna dance i'll beat the crap
out of you
get away from me almost touched that
oh location found shrine
don't touch oh
i'm poisoned my sight is worse ah my
sight my eyes
why did i touch the corpse bandage i
guess probably a good idea i shouldn't
touch those corpses
that's the answer don't touch the corpse
you won't have a problem if you don't
touch the corpse
oh god don't touch it set up that a
working bear trap
yeah it's a hidden road trap what did i
just what did it say i just found
oh god hey okay is there something there
is that a tank
is that a tank oh my god
oh there's so many of them ah it's a
tank you know tank their home
not my home tank for them not for me
they found giant hole what do you mean
giant oh that's what you mean giant hole
it's a hole it's a whole hole
alright fine where am i oh god
found road to village ah okay that's
probably useless
because everyone is saying the roads
ain't do good rhodes is do bad
you know how the roads ain't doing
anything oh
go what is that gutted
pig oh
no oh
no oh no
oh no where am i what
no stop i need but i wha
no i where
did not right at all that's not right
the chinese zone has been rendering
money i don't trust it i'm going to
leave it for now i don't know
if i pick that up if it's going to curse
me i do i don't know
anything about anything i don't know
anything about
nothing i where am i
oh hey are you hello our woods are so
beautiful this time of year
uh-huh yeah uh-huh
oh what is that is that a pig oh no
oh no oh oh no oh no
oh no oh oh no hello
hello the woman stares at the ground
with the dead look
okay i'm not going to take your doll
ma'am i kill the pig
you know i
can't help you in that it sounds like a
you thing
look at these barricades some hefty
barricades
this door seems to be blocked from the
other side yeah you'd be right about
that
seems very blocked need a key
all right whatever you say looks like
time is frozen so that at least that's
good at least i'm not wasting time here
what is yeah i can't even look at a map
you know maybe i should have taken this
shiny stone because it seems like a
special area oh
hey got it
you know i'll take it i'll take it
carefully remove the stone all right see
you around
later loser hello hi how are you
who are you good question i don't
honestly know get away from me all right
cool
you got it that's actually the most
sensible thing i've heard in a long time
that's a dead whatever that is where's
my meat uh you know
excellent question i should get two
kilos of meat for this month you know
excellent question if he ever tries to
come back
well is is it me am i the one
[ __ ] quack doctor yeah all right
generators baby oh
some not fun is happening over there oh
no
hello what now get the freak away from
my
home you know you're right there's no
more meat
the sow is starving she gives no
pigs all right get or i'll let antec
loose i don't know who antek is but
please don't
hello okay
map location found pig shed
good
a burned doctor's bag ah i remember
encountering a doctor
didn't go too good for me actually hello
old destroyed well he's been hiding in
his cottage for the last couple days
this is a lot of people i didn't think
that this sort of thing would be a thing
excuse me coming in
taking your booze don't mind just
stealing all your crap
stealing all your crap i don't want to
be in there
oh i hate oh no oh
no oh no
you can have my logs just gonna take
this
all right great oh wow shiny stone
hey you okay
i can hear you know yeah i'm talking to
you
hear you right
all right man see you around have a good
take care oh my god we got him we got
him again
we got him again him again we got no
wonder it was barricaded oh my god oh my
god oh my god
okay hey uh well i'm full up how you
guys doing hey what's up how you who are
you good question i don't know taking
your stuff
hello more stuff to rummage through
what goodies do you have here that i can
take
hi nice wardrobe a siphon
of siphon a siphon take the battery
okay bye thanks for the stuff go look at
this crate here
hope no one stops me more gas
good gracious i would love to take this
gas but i'm actually
pretty full up all right whatever uh
holes okay what do you want um it's
quite a wide tunnel
my holes there are finger marks on the
ground it must have been dug up by bare
hands i wonder where it leads
oh my god i see eyes oh my god oh my god
i
know you know what no nope no no you're
gonna have your hole
that hole is meant for you dead rad
great
what i hear you yeah you hear me yep i'm
i'm here see you between the trees yep
you
you right you very yeah it's too late
for that
too late for what okay you know what i
think
this is the village of madness and i
think that uh
the longer i stay here the more i'm
going to catch
sad madness hello
sticky with chicken feces and feathers
yeah okay
hi chicken lady oh no
no better keep them hands off me
hens you bloody scoundrel the old lady
puts one of the hens to her ear
mumbling under her breath after a moment
she calms down
i've seen me share of things lived
through many a war
but nothing like this lord be my witness
this accursed land ain't a place for men
ain't a place for hens
i got a plastic chick hell's bells where
did you get it
where did you find it the old lady seems
disturbed the hens fell silent
i can feel the tension in the air holy
mother it's
janik's little hen a gift from me
my little brother a couple of days ago
he got mad
i told him to stay you're not one of
them brainy fellas you'd know nothing
but he wouldn't listen and off he went
to that other fella
here take this he went to see this
fella see him he never came back
the lady shoves a crumpled photo in my
hand oh
i hate that every of that is awful
terrible actually the woman trembles
violently the hen on her shoulder
struggles to maintain balance
here all i have my little sisters
all right here's a road i remember this
place i do
it's been six years since i've been
there last this road used to lead to the
other village
you could also take it to get to the
city not that far away from here
you won't get there now these deliveries
trees have overgrown everything
gossip thank the lord for our sow poor
thing seems sickly but she has more life
in her than a lot of us
if you ask me only thanks to her we got
something to put in the pot these days
poor hanuska has lost her mind a fella
knocked her up with this
abomination even the mongrels tucked
their tails and yelped when they saw it
i tell ya poor soul they burned her
fella with the shack and took the horror
somewhere
everyone got the jitters little wonder
the old lady smiles kindly bearing her
three yellow teeth
it was a long time ago but you remember
it's still my little hen don't ya
okay great
holy mother this creep again may the
devil take him in his blasted violin
the old lady turns red and starts to
scream never [ __ ] you mother
get away from me house all right hey
great map
got a pig shed okay
toolbox i need that toolbox i actually
need that
to upgrade i really need that that's
incredible
tape that sounds good there's so much
good stuff all of a sudden
uh i can always get more scrap these
shiny stones are very valuable
kross i'm okay
oh no you know what that's for the best
that's for the best that's for the best
okay
hello hi
eggs okay all right you know what
you know what you know what i'm good i'm
good with all this i'm good
i'm okay i'll come back for this my
inventory is full
but i'm pretty sure this village ain't
going anywhere
if i go home didn't mean to come here
but here i am what a lovely little
hamlet
good great all right okay so that was
horrifying
really something terrible
happened in that village i'm going to
take a little bit of a circular path to
get back
just to scout out the area a little more
what is that
the silo looks like the silo tipped over
all right
cool good great also good okay
what whatever it doesn't matter okay got
those in there
okay we're gonna upgrade the workshop
boom what do i need to work it again
okay i need another toolbox so i would
have to get another toolbox
there there's bound to be a toolbox up
in the area north that i was because i
bet
there would have been one just to make
sure that you could
upgrade it so there's enough time to go
out again but
for now i'm gonna call this quits here
seeing a lot of stuff that i didn't
think i was going to see so i'm going to
stop this here
we're going to pick it up next time i'm
going to shore up the defenses we're
going to survive at night and then we're
going to go
out and we're going to explore this new
area this is awesome i love this
this is so cool there's so much here so
much weird stuff here
but so cool so thank you everybody so
much for watching
and as always i will see you in the next
video
[Music]
bye-bye
you